on va revenir sur ppda qui a été dévié
et effectivement évincé par france
télévisions puisqu'il avait il était la
voix off de l'émission de télé que les
maisons un artiste ou une maison
l'artiste est depuis le début de la
création il était la voix et ouais il
n'avait pas été en effet été enlevés
c'est une idée de lui d'ailleurs ce
qu'elle essayait de nom c'est une très
très belle c'est franchement une très
très belle émission en dehors de toute
autre considération
c'est une très très belle émission et là
ça y est c'est lui qui faisait la voix
au fond le voyez jamais un cd moment il
est
alors le voyez pas physiquement c'est
fini disons qu'il y avait beaucoup de
rediffusions on se demande aussi
pourquoi france 5 n'a pas fait un peu
plus tôt c'est vrai que
l'animateur qui ont été suspendues pour
moins que ça bourdin darius rochebin cx
là ça arrive un peu tard mais ça arrive
alors il faut rappeler que maintenant
ça s'est inversé puisque ppda maintenant
attaque exor d'innovation les 21 6 et 26
femmes il ya une seule plainte chez qui
je crois est encore pas prescrite sur
les 26 donc la sphère média peut se
terminer assez assez bien pour lui
malheureusement assez bien non je ne
suis pas bon je résume en parlant les
attaquants fait il ouvre la boîte de
pandore ll se réjouissent limites qu'ils
les attaques pour diffamation elles font
elles vont enfin pouvoir parler surtout
pour celles pour qui il ya prescription
donc en fait moi je sais pas qui est qui
lui a conseillé de faire sa part été la
pire des idées lapierre et on a un petit
extra garde et
18 femmes se tiennent main dans la main
pour accuser patrick poivre d'arvor de
violences sexuelles prendre la parole
publiquement et douloureux je le fais
vraiment pour les autres femmes face à
ces témoignages l'ancien patron de tf1 a
réagi dans cette même émission y'a pas
de système il ya simplement quelqu'un
qui se comportaient de façon odieuse
sans que personne ne puisse le savoir
puisque ces fameux s'exprimer patrick
poivre d'arvor présumé innocent a
récemment porté plainte à son tour pour
dénonciation calomnieuse alors présumé
innocent il attaque en diffamation oui
c'est sa stratégie depuis le début en
fait de nier il d'attaquer mais c'est
une stratégie qui est pas du tout payant
tu sais ce qu'il a fait dans quotidien
au début ils disent oui rappelez vous
ces femmes de toutes façons disent
n'importe quoi puisque c'est ce qu'elles
sont anonymes qu'est ce qu'elles ont
fait elles ont témoigné à visage
découvert là ils osent entre guillemets
les attaquer en justice je pense que ça
va donné lieu à de nouveaux témoignages
ou pour moi c'est une stratégie qui est
très mauvaise de la part de bp dont il
avait parlé d'ailleurs à l'époque de
justement à l'époque c'était un peu
différent le comportement même c'est
toujours condamnable d'imiter un petit
bisou dans le cou il a même reconnu ça
il l'a dit en fait il y avait des
rumeurs qui fait sur le bd à papa en
gros une bêtise l'école avait été peint
un dragueur lourd il y avait je crois il
a réfuté ça je crois pas que hilliard
yens 5 6 ans m'ont été on avait
conscience qu'il ya eu des viols en tant
que tel et quand on voit les témoignages
certaines jeunes femmes et deux femmes
se voilent a fait de l'agression
sexuelle pure et dure dure et dure dans
l'année on a dit on va juste regarder
lire le témoignage de marie laure de
lattre regarde et je me suis retrouvé
dans l'ascenseur avec lui et je me suis
dit bon comme il m'avait dit qu'on
allait voir impôts je me suis dit je
vais aller boire un pot sur la terrasse
est en fait je me suis retrouvé dans sa
chambre et après je les ai vus tout nu
comme un ver se frotter sur son canapé
qu'est ce que vous faites là moi je suis
pas bon pour ça et j'ai pas bougé je me
souviens juste que j'étais allongé qui
m'a enlevé mon pantalon on ma culotte
qu'il est rentré ding dong ding dong moi
j'étais collé comme ça c'est tout ce qui
s'est passé la séduction excusez moi
mais c'est pas ça c'est bout de viande
j'en ai besoin je le prends et je m'en
vais quand il a fait fakih la dgi qui
est en moi juste après c'était je savais
que ça paierait donc il est dans une
autre dimension je pense donc une autre
dimension ray oui non mais je pense
qu'il est c'est effroyable se tait moyen
est affreusement effroyable mais je
pense qu'on est dans une doute il est
dans une autre dimension je pense que
patrick poivre d'arvor est toujours dans
sa tête cet homme puissant qu'il est
patrick poivre d'arvor acculé par ses 26
femmes son comportement est anormal
c'est une maladie c'est une pathologie
quand vous voyez comment cette femme
parle de la star du 20 heures celui qui
réunit le plus de téléspectateurs devant
son journal vous avez vu comment elle en
parle c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
se retrouve face à un type qui s'agite
comme un ver sur le sur le sur son os
sur sur le lit mais c'est c'est je
trouve ça long l'effroyable est alors
quand on parle effectivement
des problèmes de la problématique de
prescription mais vous pouvez pour elle
c'est pas possible ça parle quand même
de gens qui ont été pour certains violet
en 2004 et 2009 et qui vivent avec ça
depuis pour certaines 20 ans dont ka
mandé je pense que c'est impossible que
cette affaire soit classée le reste est
comment lui à l'être sur ça aujourd'hui
c'est incroyable qu'à la camp quand je
dis que ça aide bien ça mais n'est
juridiquement pour lui honnêtement c'est
très froid by minute est très probable
qu'ils s'en tirent bien c'est ce que moi
ce qui me ce qui est vraiment me fait
vomir et ce que je trouve vraiment
terrible c'est cette plainte en
diffamation qui fait contre ces femmes
c'est à dire que c'est la double peine
et c'est ça qui est immonde et quand
elle s'exprime la plupart des femmes
disent on aurait aimé qu'il admette
parce que le fait qu'il admette ça leur
faisait un petit peu du bien ça voulait
dire on vous croit vous n'avez pas menti
oui j'ai fait ça peut-être qu'à l'époque
mais j'ai pété un câble mais je les fais
et voilà c'est une manière aussi de
s'excuser là il continue il enfonce le
conte c'est ça qui est terrible en
flandre quand quand nicolas dit qu il
est dans son bon je pense que je pense
que là c'est sincèrement quand ce
malheureusement dans sa tête il pense
vraiment qu'il n'a rien fait de mal
c'est ça n'autorise et c'est pour ça que
c'est grave c'est sa notorité qui peut
être l'a rendu fou parce qu'il avait un
statut de quasiment de rockstar de 2,2
du jt le chanteur il avait des conquêtes
des dizaines de conquête qui était
consentante aussi et peut-être que lui
dans sa tête un moment il a vrillé ceni
voilà toutes les femmes veulent toutes
les femmes désirent et ça se tire sans
ses
employés quand vous parlez guillaume
quand tu parles de consentons jeu
pendant que lui malade est persuadé que
les femmes était content parce qu'il
s'est pris pour un c
aujourd'hui c'est la loi aujourd'hui il
est présumé innocent bien sûr voilà et
j'aurais contamine avait sur dossier
avec le témoignage de nonce paolini qui
est arrivé je crois en 2010 ou en 2008 à
la direction de tf1 et qui dit qu' il
n'était pas au courant tous les cas de
l'ampleur du phénomène regardez c'est à
la fois
stupéfiants les révoltant
abusé de la position dans laquelle on
est pour se livrer à ce genre de
harcèlement ou plus
c'est révoltant si dans une entreprise
comme tf1 on l'avait su
évidemment des sanctions ont été prises
si on l'avait su on aurait pris les
dispositions qui s'imposent et en tout
cas moi le premier tous les témoignages
disent que c'était un sens bureau après
la conférence de rédaction et après 21h
à 21h à tf1 il n'y a plus personne donc
qui pouvait savoir alors non c'est
d'ailleurs là je crois que c'est lui qui
étaient là qui a viré et ppda est mal
parce que quand j'étais à tf1 il m'avait
parlé moi j'étais un peu en fait avec
eux aussi m'avait dit tu sais les
meubles ici parce qu'on est un peuple
qu'on n'est pas des ménages abbey les
mariés prendre les cas si on les aide
pas être pas été viré pour ça non pas du
tout dans mais c'est lui qui avait pris
la décision de sortir de pda de
l'antenne pas du tout par rapport à ça
je pense que sincèrement quand il est
arrivé il n'avait pas conscience de
l'ampleur du phénomène et sur ce qui
peut être pas le cas de l'ancienne
direction mais voilà c'est bien le cas
des histoires contes n'ont pas entendu
parler notamment à l'époque de claire
chazal était voilée de patrick le pays
dont à l'époque de tf1 qui elle même
avait été agressée d'ailleurs hockey
innocent et j'entends le truc pas là
quand même témoigner sur le fait qu'elle
avait été agressée par patrick poivre
d'arvor mais n'oublions pas surtout une
chose c'est que quand vous êtes ne
serait ce qu'une femme par exemple dans
une entreprise et que vous êtes face à
quelqu'un d'aussi puissant patrick
poivre d'arvor c'était quasiment le
super président de tf1 l'angoissé la
peur c'est d'en parler à quelqu'un qui
pourrait nuire à vous croire puisque
qu'est ce qui se passe à ce moment là
c'est vous qui vous fait virer quand
vous dites que il peut s'en sortir
juridiquement peut-être mais pas
médiatiquement ne risque pas mais la
victoire sur ce
nouveau contrat mais j'aurai un gars que
je regarde c'est un pas
qui veut dire qu'elles sont très
heureuses que qui est un pro si sûr
c'est muriel reus qui mène ça on la voit
là la blonde jolie blonde à côté mitu
médias qu'elle a créé avec toutes ces
femmes toutes ces payante évidemment et
c'est grâce à ce procès que like on dire
des choses ils vont pouvoir en parler